so democrats have a joe biden problem
and boy do they have a solution one
democratic strategist has the perfect
candidate to save the party in 2024 who
he calls quote an influencer in the
purest form and a smart photogenic
congresswoman so who may it be
uh i know somebody who's gonna turn 35
about a month before the election in
2024
and uh they represent new york's 14th
if democrats ditch their political
equivalent of yoda they can save
themselves a ton of headaches with aoc
they won't have to worry about winning
over the far left base she already
embraces their platform
capitalism has not always existed in the
world and it will not always exist in
the world i think that there's a lot of
people
more concerned about being
precisely
factually and semantically correct than
about being morally right the world is
going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change your biggest
issue is
how are we going to pay for it talking
about
the reduction of our nypd budget and
defunding a six billion dollar nypd
budget inevitable
ah yes
jill biden can rest easy knowing she
will no longer have to convince the
american people that her husband is
doing a good job and have to say things
like quote i don't want to sound like a
political ad but we've done so much
gas prices are a huge issue and joe is
every single day on the phone talking to
leaders about gas and oil but i wish
people could see more of what joe has
accomplished and how hard he's working
and democrats won't have to be bothered
with trying to answer this very tough
question
do you want to see joe biden run for a
second term
yeah i you know that's an easy question
that's not going to take long do you
want to see joel i don't want to answer
that question because we have not that's
not yet i don't want to answer that
question
i'm working on my own election and
that's all i'm focused on right now i'm
not talking about the 2022 election and
2024. i have no control over those
elections and i'm not going to talk
about them that's all i'm going to talk
about you're a democratic senator i'm
just i'm just asking you whether you
would support your own oh jeez
but the one big thing she has over her
fellow dems she's not old and decrepit
here's jerry nadler in a debate last
night making a curious boast
and that and i have passed the um
two impeachments in my in leading this
i've impeached
bush twice
first question is uh the first thing
about seniority with seniority comes
clout
and the ability to get things done
that's the way congress works
um
seniority brings you clout uh it brings
you the ability to get things done
second well the second question what was
your second question
i think we found someone who might
actually be worse than joe or kamala
which raises the question why is it that
only the good people leave politics but
the bad never ever go away
so uh jesse i i you know we're not like
the left we don't like completely go
into derangement syndrome over their uh
they're talented leaders we like look at
them we examine them and i think i can
say that aoc has a skill set but she's
missing things like knowledge
but with with age comes wisdom and she's
pretty young
that's my nice way of saying she's not
very smart
she's like you know when you like pick a
banana and you the banana is in your
hand and it's green and then even if you
try to peel it it's still not even
peeling yes that's aoc she's not ripe
enough to run for president first
she has to get married
she has to plan a wedding or you want to
plan a wedding and run for president at
the same time oh i see what you mean
okay so then her husband would have to
do it and the wedding would stink
because she said getty she just got
engaged she's engaged yes
and then you have to get pregnant so why
no no this is how it goes this is i'm
giving this is how it goes just follow
me greg
following you then you get pregnant and
then once you have the baby you have a
family right and the media loves it
ate it up and it makes you more of a
mature person that's why you're so
immature you don't have any kids so then
after she has the family then she runs
for senate she runs for senate in new
york you get to meet all the big time
donors you get into the senate and then
you're a force to be reckoned with at
the hearings
and then
she runs for president obama first term
from illinois that's the way to do it
because right now she's not really seen
as a serious person she's childish she
fakes her arrest she's giving makeup
tips but if you give it maybe i would
say 10 years would that be uh
2032
then she'd be ripe enough to run for
president because she can't unify the
party right now everybody in the party
most of them hate her yeah and i think
after 10 years she could unify the party
but now do you think she could today win
a state like
michigan
or
north carolina or wisconsin or
pennsylvania there's no way someone like
aoc could do that i just i can see our
producer right now just ran into traffic
over there
i could see it i could actually hear her
screaming
so you basically um
no that's the that's the formula henry
harold
i was so overcome by his strategizing
harold
we know what you mean you're talking
about you have to create some kind of
appealing i don't know whatever but
harold i
i have a theory that like it's it's
happening in a lot of industries media
and academia a lot of people are getting
are leaving certain areas where there's
wokism and the people that are left
behind that's all there is and i think
that's does that happen that's why you
were here you're not right if you ran
for president you would win but you're
not you're not running for president
so you think he'd won
are you kidding me saying democrat
absolutely absolutely not
seeing democrats so i'll remind
everybody in 1982 when ronald reagan was
president there's a headline an abc news
poll that that came out right in the
summertime about this time that said
almost 60 of americans did not want
ronald reagan to seek re-election
two years later he won 49 states beating
walter mondale
this may or may not happen with with joe
biden but certainly there's time to do
this you can't have one op-ed by a
political consultant whom i don't know
saying that that she's going to run for
president could be president i think
there's some things that jesse said a
lot of elements that jesse said is right
there's some maturing that you have to
do in politics that's a better word than
right
there there's so there's a vision you
have to lay out for the country and with
that time
with time you're able to do some of
those things i think that a number of us
in the party who don't agree with some
of the positions that some of my some in
that element of the party wing of the
party the progressive wing the positions
they may take look at this guy the
positions they may take uh
uh within the party whether or not those
ideas are the ones that are going to
sustain and help the country build you
think about what we're dealing with just
yesterday with the speaker of the house
leading a delegation to taiwan the truth
of the matter is we need a better
coherent a new strategy uh as it relates
to that region of the world it needs to
involve uh an effort that deals with
trade investment
uh national security and human rights
and how you calibrate that i've not
heard you know those particularly those
in the progressive wing speak about
these kinds of issues speak about the
kind of investments we need to make in
our country if they do that
perhaps you could be a viable candidate
maybe next time or even four six eight
years from now how would i know you know
but you bring up uh
nancy pelosi
um degan so you have the speaker of the
house right she's i don't know how old
she is you got joe biden you know
whatever jerry nadler isn't the appeal
have to a bit to do with age isn't the
real story here about new blood uh and
and you see this guy who mistaking uh
trump for bush and he's just looks like
a sickly wind bag and this is what i
mean this is what we're dealing with he
has a lot of clout he has a lot of i
mean that's what he's saying he says
elect me because i've been here forever
maybe go away yeah when i see jerry
nadler i always go do i have stuff on my
shoulders like
anybody who's ever seen jared nedler
knows what i'm talking about so as women
do i made a list of pros and cons like
where we're going to get a new guy or
get a new dog
for aoc a presidency a run for the
presidency um the pros are she's a
babbling brook of quotable quotes like
dope tropes i call them she's great at
keeping lipstick off her teeth
which is really difficult and she is the
poster abroad of me-ism so you don't get
into politics and run for the highest
office in the land unless you're about
uh yourself and not about the betterment
of the american people the betterment of
all her biggest problem and there's only
one con
it's the fact that we know what an aoc
presidency would look like and we the
american people are already bearing the
burden and feeling the pain of that
because joe biden and company and the
democrats in the senate and the house
have completely lifted all of these
left-wing ideas from aoc's clan we have
runaway inflation a federal reserve
aiding and abetting
the politicians sopping up what three
quarters of all the new debt we have
fossil fuels our way of life standard of
living has completely been crushed
they're telling us to buy a six-figure
electric vehicle and go what's the
problem don't you love your suv
and then
open the borders empty the prisons chaos
crime and death i guess the the only a
good thing going for is that she seems
to be able to cry on cue as we witness
at the border so that might help her if
she runs last word katie what do you
think of this obviously this was not a
serious idea but uh you know hey slow
news day right well it's amazing how
we're not talking about what a second
biden term would actually look like
first of all exactly uh
look running for president isn't
necessarily about winning the presidency
and if pete butterjudge can run for
president i think aoc can run for
president right he was able to run for
president after being a very terrible
mayor of south bend he's now a cabinet
member still not great at his job
aoc doesn't have a great record in
congress she is ranked one of the worst
in terms of getting legislation passed
that she's introduced in new york she's
dead last when it comes to all the
representatives in this state
but maybe she doesn't need that she is
charismatic i don't think that
republicans should underestimate her she
has a social media presence
she knows how to get attention from the
media just like president trump yeah in
certain ways and so you know
the party is shifting towards the left
the
problem for her and the left right now
is that america is running away from
woke-ism and they're losing their
coalition but in terms of her running
again i don't see why she couldn't
take the plunge and like you said i mean
they people when they were pushing trump
they were laughing about yes and who got
the last laugh right so you know i think
she's formidable she just needs some
maturing
jesse ripening
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now